[Music]
hey rob it's me eric tyler from indiana
and i've got a question let me ask you
something man
if you're in the house and you run out
of bread
and all you've got are hot dog and
hamburger buns
which one do you use to eat
meat on i mean it doesn't even have to
be meat it can be chilly or something
like that
they're like is there a difference
eatability taste wise that's what i want
to know
thanks rob harry count well eric you
indianans
which by the way you're called hoosiers
i know you know that you're from indiana
as my family is um i
had a hot dog last night and had a full
debate with myself
at the dodger game whether i was going
to take it out of the bun
or not um
[Music]
i went with the bun twice in fact
and i kind of regret it um
[Music]
but you cannot eat a hot dog without
though because it's round and slippery
and what have you
because with with um burgers now i just
i eat them protein style i just use the
lettuce
as the bread product so i guess it's a
long-winded way
of saying i
don't give a crap about the the the the
um
bun on a hamburger hamburger buns are
they could cease to exist and i my life
wouldn't change appreciably
at all so if there was a fire in my
house
and and i had both of them my the one i
would run out
carrying like a little baby would be the
hot dog bun because i don't know how to
hot dog without that
and that sir is my answer